retro wrecking tour here guys I'm just a
dad who loves games and the stories they
tell and today we're covering everything
you need to know about the story of Star
Wars Jedi Fallen order and we're doing
it in seven minutes or less Star Wars
Jedi Fallen order is a third person
action adventure game developed by
respawn entertainment and published by
EA the adventure kicks off on the planet
Baraka where calcustus a former Jedi
Padawan works as a salvager he's on the
run from the Empire after the execution
of Order 66 which places the game after
Revenge of the Sith but before Return of
the Jedi Cal is attempting to live out
his life as a normal dude but his cover
is blown after he needs to use his Force
powers to save his friend Prof of course
this alerts the Empire and they send
over a couple of inquisitors former Jedi
trained by Vader himself to hunt down
Cow Prof comes forward claiming he is
the Jedi and before Cal can do anything
to help his friend is killed by the
second sister gal then attacks with his
lightsaber and now they know he's really
the Jedi they were looking for all along
and an absolutely epic escape sequence
callus eventually rescued by Seer junda
and a pilot named Grease dritas once
aboard the ship Cal questions Seer
asking how she knows so much and why
she's helping him see your Tails Cal
they're on a mission to restore the Jedi
Order but that the council is gone they
set their sights on the planet Pagano
which holds a vault Seer believes
contains the key to rebuilding the Jedi
Order it's on the ship we also learned
Cal has a unique ability to physically
touch an object and witness events
connected to it through these Force
Echoes he can feel its history this
becomes a recurring element throughout
the game as Cal can touch certain
objects in the world to learn more about
them Seer also reveals she was once a
Jedi and that she knew cow's Master
Charles of Paul Cal opens up to Seer by
letting her know his connection to the
force is damaged and that it's way too
easy for him to lose control this
doesn't seem to deter her though as she
still wants his help on Pagano cow
begins exploring that planet in search
of the Vault and it's there a droid
named bd1 catches up with him and
provides assistance along the way BD
proves to be a reliable companion
capable of scanning objects opening
doors and even helping Cal to ride
across zip lines once they make it to
the Vault BD shares a message from
former Jedi Master Eno Cordova Cordova
reveals he had a vision about the fall
of the Jedi but prepared for it by
creating a holocron containing a list of
names and locations of young Force
sensitives throughout the Galaxy of
course Cordova doesn't plan on giving up
these secrets to just anyone he's
arranged a series of tests kalma's first
pass before he can get inside the Vault
and retrieve the holocron the crew sets
out for the planet zepha where they need
to locate the tombs belonging to three
zepho sages inside the first Tomb Cal
gets another message from Cordova this
one instructing him to find a Chieftain
Wookie named tarful on the planet
kashyyk in route to kashyyk sear lets us
in a bit more in her past like the fact
that you know Cordova was once her
master we also learned after The Purge
she and her Padawan took several
younglings and went into hiding
Unfortunately they didn't last long
before Seer was captured and even
tortured until she gave up the location
of the others Cal arrives on kashyyk but
tarful is nowhere to be found we do
discover there are a number of Wookies
being held captive by the Empire and Cal
decides to land a hand there instead
along the way he runs into the
resistance leader Saul Guerrera who
offers to help Cal find tarful Saul even
tries to recruit Cal into fighting
alongside the resistance buddy declines
before they can track tarful down the
crew gets word that the Empire is
heading to a sage tomb back on zepho so
they backtrack to the planet and Cal
meets up again with the second sister
after an epic lightsaber battle between
the two she reveals her identity as
trila AKA Sears former Padawan she
blames cyr for giving her up to the
Empire and tells Cali wouldn't have
found her otherwise he gets away from
Trilla thanks to BD's help and the duo
quickly make their way to the tomb of
miktroll inside Cal continues repairing
his connection to the force as he
recalls memories from training with his
master another recurring element
throughout the game this time he learns
for his pull which he'll need to fully
explore the tomb not long after getting
back his Force pull ability BD has
another message ready from Cordova turns
out Cordova discovered a zepho artifact
called an astrium which allows a force
wielder to perceive the mysteries of the
Vault they head back to the ship but
they're ambushed by a bounty hunter
working for The haxian Brood apparently
gries has a gambling debt that he hasn't
repaid and So Cal must battle his way
out by fighting in a combat Arena Sierra
and Greece arrive just in time to save
the day and rescue Cal they make their
way back back to kashyyk and finally
meet up with tarful thanks to help from
Saul tarful gives Cal the information he
needs which ultimately leads to another
message from Cordova this one pointing
our hero to the planet dathomir in
search of the astrium before they can
leave kalamus get past the ninth sister
who's tracked them down on kashyyk after
taking her down an epic lightsaber
battle the crew leaves for dathomir upon
their arrival there Cal is confronted by
Marin a night sister who blames the Jedi
for the slaughter of her sisters shortly
after the encounter with Marin he meets
yet another new face who is only
described as Wanderer at this point in
the game he warns Cal not to go into the
tomb and that it isn't safe but of
course Cal trudges on and we flash back
to another memory this one taking place
the very moment that order 66 went into
effect we first witnessed the death of
DePaul through cow's eyes as a young
Padawan but then we snap back into the
present and battle the spirit version of
our former master in a rage Cal stabs to
Paul but it shatters the kyber crystal
within his lightsaber before leaving
dathomir the wanderer's true identity is
actually revealed as Taryn malikos
another former Jedi who's unfortunately
turned to the dark side of course Cal
turns him down but then Marin shows up
angry at malikos for wanting to work
with a Jedi we escape and forms here of
everything that's happened back on the
ship and with her encouragement Cal
agrees to travel to a loom and retrieve
another kyber Crystal a trip there
results in Cal not only finding another
kyber Crystal but also another message
from Cordova this one inspiring him to
finish what he started it's here we also
learned that bd1 willingly had his
memory erased to conceal the Pagano
Vault armed with a new lightsaber
calicrue head back to dathomir where
he's again confronted by Marin Cal
explains it wasn't the Jedi who killed
Maron sisters and the two come to an
understanding as Cal makes his way into
the tomb to retrieve the astrum were
confronted Again by malakose caltries
one more time to help him see the error
of his ways but of course it ends in
another you guessed it epic lightsaber
duel Maron even shows up at the end of
the fight to give us the upper hand and
agrees to join Cal and his crew to help
them finish their mission they go back
to Pagano and just as we're preparing to
retrieve the holocron Drilla attacks
once again in another epic lightsaber
duel yes so remember that special
ability that Cal has to see Echoes of
memories there ends up being a moment in
this fight just when he's getting the
the upper hand and even manages to grab
trilla's lightsaber unfortunately this
triggers the memory of what happened
between Seer and Trilla in the past
which gives trila in the present just
the time she needs to grab the holocron
and Escape seeing trilla's lightsaber
and hearing what happened to Cal sear
now knows she can't stand on the
sidelines any longer she takes up the
lightsaber names Khalid Jedi Knight and
sets their course for the Fortress
inquisitorious to take back the holocron
from Trilla Cal battles his way through
numerous enemies along the way but
eventually makes it to the very chamber
where Seer was tortured Trill attacks
and its epic lightsaber battle time
again where Cal emerges Victorious sear
shows up and apologizes to her former
Padawan and just when it seems like
everything is going to work out so
nicely the legend himself Darth Vader
arrives on the scene he promptly kills
Trilla toss a Seer to the side like a
ragdoll and attempts to take the
holocron for himself no match for the
Sith Lord all Cal can do is run and try
to escape with the holocron with the
help of BD a way more powerful than we
realize Seer and even Marin Our Heroes
escape with the holocron which contains
the names for all of the four sensitive
chill children in the Galaxy knowing
that nothing will stop Vader from coming
after the holocron rather than using it
to search for the children on their own
Cal decides to leave everything to the
force and destroys it instead and that
is Star Wars Jedi Fallen order in 7
minutes or less if you'd like to see my
full playthrough of Star Wars Jedi fall
in order check out the let's play on the
right side of your screen now as always
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon